[Music]
consciousness has found its notion in
utility but it is partly still an object
and partly for that very reason still an
end to be attained which consciousness
does not find itself to possess
immediately utility is still a predicate
of the object not itself a subject or
the immediate and sole actuality of the
object it is the same thing that
appeared before when being for self had
not yet shown itself to be the substance
of the other moments a demonstration
which would have meant that the useful
was directly nothing else but the self
of consciousness and that this latter
was thereby in possession of it this
withdrawal from the form of objectivity
of the useful has however already taken
place in principle and from this inner
revolution there emerges the actual
revolution of the actual world the new
shape of consciousness absolute freedom
with paragraph 582 we now begin a new
and actually final section of this
middle portion of the massive spirit
part of the work this one is called
absolute freedom and terror in general
this has been understood as Hegel's
engagement at least in part not not
entirely but at least in part with the
French Revolution which at you know
makes perfect sense because what we've
been looking at this entire time is the
struggle of enlightenment to not only
you know struggle against the faith and
the culture that it emerges from but
also to figure out what enlightenment
actually is and so you know where does
the enlightenment you might say get its
greatest traction in terms of society
and culture I mean you can point to
several places you can point to Great
Britain England itself Scotland there's
a Scottish enlightenment going on
Germany itself enlightenment thought is
also you know affecting things in Italy
and in Spain and other places of course
there's an entire development happening
in America but France is really where
the rubber meets the road in the most
important way in a way that is affecting
Hegel's own time he is writing this in
the midst of the Napoleonic Wars when
the French Revolution has been going on
now for in effect you know more than a
decade and you know new shapes of
governance if not necessarily of
consciousness have developed in the
process is this something that only
applies to the the the French Revolution
and you know how it begins by trying to
affirm these universal human values and
that eventually lapses into the terror
no it's applicable in many other cases
as well but
it's useful to bear that in mind Hegel
here is going to end this paragraph by
telling us that in this section we're
dealing with a new shape of
consciousness a new Gestalt
Despero signs right and what is that
shape it is absolute freedom notice that
as we go through these paragraphs there
is another absolute that's lurking you
know at the very end of the book
absolute knowing we're getting something
sketched out that comes close to what
Hegel is calling absolute knowing but it
doesn't quite get there we have to pass
through some other things on the way so
let's pick up with the text down Hegel
says consciousness has found its notion
in utility that's you know what has been
going on throughout the entire truth of
enlightenment section it was a result at
the end of it it also came up earlier in
the struggle of enlightenment with with
superstition or insight and faith
utility being useful making oneself
useful understanding things in terms of
how they can contribute to or how they
impede something else this is a key idea
and we often associate utilitarianism
with people like Jeremy Bentham and then
John Stuart Mill and so there's a
tendency I think for people who are not
reading a lot of Enlightenment thought
to mistakenly think that utilitarianism
is something absolutely new on the scene
or this emphasis on utility is radically
new coming about and maybe the late
1700s right totally not the case if you
read the authors of the 17th and 18th
centuries you will see this term useful
utility util in French coming up over
and over and over and over again
plays a major role in Humes thought it
plays a major role in thought going all
the way back to Hobbes so this is going
to be an important insight consciousness
has found its notion it's but if it's
its understanding not just of the world
but of itself in utility so how do we
parse that out what does that mean then
for us he says it's partly still an
object against on something objective in
the sense of being something out there
existing for it and partly says for that
very reason still an end vac purpose
project can also be translation and end
to be attained
so he says consciousness does not find
itself to possess this immediately so
there's a kind of splitting going on
here again within consciousness
consciousness is aware of itself as what
is useful as you might say if we want to
play a little bit on Aristotle and
Aristotle called the hand the tool of
tools right the organ on that manages
and produces all the other what it be
we're gonna yeah we could say that the
usefulness of consciousness is that
which activates or realizes or
manipulates the usefulness of everything
else including what else can be objects
for us like other people or societal
norms all right so he goes on he says
this is an interesting utility is a
predicate of the object not itself a
subject or the immediate and sole
actuality of the object we want to bring
these two points of view and and an
object and it means together right or
you might say object and larger project
that the object fits into where were the
subject B we've got the object utility
is a predicate of the object
consciousness be understood as the
subject should the end be understood is
it should the subject be understood as
this incorporation of all of these into
each other
that's not spelled out here by Hegel he
just tells us that it's not yet a
predicate of the subject all right so he
says this is the same thing that
appeared before when being herself had
not yet shown itself to be the substance
of the other moments a demonstration he
says which would have meant that the
useful was directly nothing else than
the self of consciousness and that this
latter was thereby in possession of it
so that's what we're aiming at or at
least that's what we're driving for at
this point this is what consciousness
wants for itself but it's not yet there
it hasn't yet grasped itself in terms of
the what you know what utility really
means at its fullness so he goes on and
he says this withdrawal from the form of
objectivity of the useful has already
taken place in principle you know again
very typical Hegelian move how can Hegel
say that it has already taken place in
principle because he is looking
backwards over the developments of
consciousness that have taken place
already this is a Gestalt a shape of
consciousness that he is familiar with
not because it's simply appearing now in
the present but because it's it's it's a
appeared in the recent past so he tells
us that there's two revolutions to you
know changing of things
ooomph out song as is the term it's
being translated as revolution here
which are we going to be looking at
first he says there's an inner
revolution right from this inner
revolution what inner revolution the the
fact that the the meaning of utility has
become for the consciousness opened up
it started to grasp this but this has to
be made actual this has to be made
worldly this has to be injected into
society says there emerges an actual
revolution of the actual world a new
shape of consciousness so the new shape
of consciousness absolute freedom
doesn't actually arrive on the scene
until the social conditions make it make
it conducive for it they allow for it
now how is this going to play out that's
what we have to see in the next 13
paragraphs comprising this short section
in fact what we have here is no more
than an empty show of objectivity
separating self-consciousness from
possession for partly all existence and
validity of the specific members of the
organization of the actual world and the
world of faith have in general returned
into this simple determination as into
their ground and spiritual principle
partly however this simple determination
no longer possesses anything of its own
it is rather pure metaphysic pure notion
or a pure knowing by self consciousness
that is to say of the being in and for
itself of the useful khwab jecht
consciousness recognizes that it's being
in itself is essentially a being for an
other being in itself as devoid of self
is in truth a passive self or that which
is a self for another self the object
however exists for consciousness in this
abstract form of pure being in itself
for consciousness is pure insight whose
distinctions are in the pure form of
notions but the being for self into
which being for another returns that is
the self is not a self belonging
exclusively to what is called object and
distinct from the eye for consciousness
qua peer insight is not a single self
which could be confronted by the object
as equally having a self of its own but
is pure notion the gazing of the self
into the self the absolute seeing of
itself doubled the certainty of itself
is the universal subject and its
conscious notion is the essence of all
actuality if then the useful was merely
the alternation of the moments an
alternation which did not return into
its own unity and hence was still an
object for knowing it now ceases to be
this for knowing is itself the movement
of those abstract moments it is the
universal self the self of itself as
well as of the object and as universal
is the self returning unity of this
movement
in paragraph 583 Hegel is going to use
the term metaphysic to describe what's
going on here and that's well worth
dwelling on and it's it's just a
transliteration of the German meta
physique which is you know of course
coming from the traditional word for
metaphysics long established by it by
that time
why is Hegel invoking that he brought
that up a little bit earlier in the
previous section why is he making that
central here in telling us that what
we've got here is a pure metaphysic a
pure notion or a pure knowing by self
consciousness so before we go into the
text let's dwell a little bit on what we
mean when we're using this term
metaphysic and and it covers a lot of
ground in part because there isn't just
one single conception of what
metaphysics is as a matter of fact you
know Heidegger later on is going to
point out to us that there's a whole
series of epochs and we don't have to
buy totally into his his narrative that
he's giving us there in order to see
what what's actually good in it which is
that we can say well you know in this
philosophy or movement or way of
thinking about things in this if we want
to use Hegel shape of consciousness
being capital B is understood by
reference to this range of beings
lowercase B that are operating is a kind
of a paradigm you know we might think
about our contemporary approach to
technology as involving a kind of
metaphysics that is different than a
metaphysics that focuses on organic
things and their natural growth or
perhaps we can bring them together a
metaphysic in its original sense means
going beyond the sensible world of
change it doesn't mean that there isn't
any change in the metaphysical realm so
the way Plato might have thought
but it's not going to be exactly the
same as what we're seeing out here in in
the actual world a metaphysics provides
a kind of intelligibility to the
grounding of that which goes beyond the
phenomena so is that what Hegel means by
a metaphysics here I think yes that's
that's pretty close he's talking about
something you know we've already seen
this you know in the previous
discussions we have the world of culture
and already that world is not just a
simply natural world a world of
phenomena ideas are playing a major role
in it moral values are playing a major
role and then we get something you know
eclipsing that transcending that world
and also still remaining in contact with
it these twin siblings faith and
enlightenment both of which are forms of
pure thought we move beyond that and the
truth of the Enlightenment was utility
so utility as opposed to being something
that is merely this worldly as we often
represent it to ourselves there is a
metaphysic behind it
underlying it according to Hegel and
it's one that takes on you you might say
historical weight almost like a snowball
you know taking a good century the
century of the Enlightenment to attain
its full weight and velocity so we're
going to come back to this in a moment
he says let's look at the tax he says
what we have here is no more than an
empty show of objectivity separating
self-consciousness from possession
looking at the problematic of the
earlier paragraph what is it also
separating consciousness from possession
the end that's vak the purpose so there
was a kind of splitting going on there
and Hegel says this this is overcome
actually but it's not overcome just in
the isolated individual it's going to be
overcome on a much grander scale so he
says all existence
yeah existence is fine be stayin right
all existence all actuality all being
established Alba Stan all existence and
validity galtung right all worth all it
mattering of the specific members of the
organization the Glee Dern the we could
say elements if you like we can say
aspects whatever you want to say all the
specific members of the organization of
the actual world the veer click about
and the world of faith giggle Optive alt
here the world that I mean you can call
it the world of faith the world that is
believed in the world to which we give
credence so this could go beyond just
the shape of consciousness of faith
enlightenment itself has its belief as
we've seen in the critique that that
faith was able to give of enlightenment
and enlightenment of itself so he says
all existence and validity of the
specific members of the organization of
the actual world and the world of faith
have returned into this simple
determination as into their ground
goodand foundation and their spiritual
principle so everything that's been
going on in society all this sort of
seemingly chaotic dynamics that led us
into what looked like impasses and then
you know led to new realizations at
least on the part of some many people
remaining mired in that and then
introducing new shapes of consciousness
like the one that we're working with now
that we're utility is the centerpiece
these are all becoming part of one big
system they're being brought together
into a unity like it or not understand
it or not they don't really have much of
a choice about it because they're not
where the initiative as far as spirit
goes resides so he goes on and he says
partly however this simple determination
right the simple determination that
they're being returned into no longer
possesses anything of its own now here
it's that's an interesting thing to say
it is a pure metaphysic so it doesn't
possess anything of its own right
pure notion pure PKF or a pure knowing
of vision right in this case right pure
knowing by self consciousness
Zeb's Babu's side are all these the same
thing is a metaphysics the same thing as
a notion the same thing as a pure
knowing by self consciousness the answer
is sometimes yes and in this case these
can be understood as synonyms but don't
take them as synonyms just across the
board so he goes on and he says now here
we get these categories right being the
being in and for itself of the useful
qua object-- consciousness recognizes
now look at splitting apart the being
for self and the being in itself it
recognizes that it's being in itself is
not as intrinsic as it would like it to
be why not because if it remains just
being in itself it can't really be what
it's supposed to be I gotta think of
what is self consciousness self
consciousness does not exist by itself
it exists in relation to and other and
other who has to be an other self
consciousness so Hegel here tells us
that consciousness recognizes its being
in itself is essentially being for
another my being what I am in myself is
contingent upon my being for and other
who's that other you're that other
somebody else watching this is also that
other and they are an other to you as
well as to me
we can also talk in terms of sort of a
generic other
this might be viewed and talked about
long after you and I are dead there's
other others yet to come so this is part
of the very structure of consciousness
as we saw in the self consciousness
section we never leave that totally
behind for Hegel right you never get
away from that the best that we can do
is somehow incorporate my relation to
the other so it's not simply
antagonistic and we go all the way back
to the master-slave dialectic there's no
worry about that here at this point
though so the being for another he says
being in itself is devoid of self is in
truth passive or that which is a self
for another self and then it says the
object however exists for consciousness
in this pure this abstract form of pure
being and itself what's the object the
object is utility again right so he says
consciousness is pure insight whose
distinctions are in the pure form of
notions now here we get the important
transition the being for self into which
being for another returns Hegel says
it's not simply that my being in myself
being in itself of what it is to be this
guy is just turned into something that
is for another it returns to me as my
being for self so what we have here is a
relation to the other that is not just
antagonism not just competition we are
providing each other with the meaning of
who we are with in actual society in
terms of usefulness I am useful for you
you are useful for me we are useful for
the larger whole so he goes on and he
says here we go the being for self into
which being for another returns the self
is not a self belonging exclusively to
what is called object and distinct from
the eye so he says for consciousness qua
pure insight is
a single single self-consciousness is
not just my consciousness or your
consciousness or the two of them set up
totally existing on their own and then
only after that having a relation no
consciousness is bigger than us we can
talk about the consciousness that runs
throughout a social group or a society
or a world age spirit whether it was
what Hegel is calling Geist spirits
there was a reason he calls it world
spirit as well he goes on and he says
it's not a single self which could be
confronted by the object as equally
having a self of its own it's pure
notion a gazing of the self into the
self the absolute seeing of itself
double this is what we're talking about
here the pure notion pure knowing by
self consciousness pure knowing what
knowing itself knowing itself in
relation to the other knowing itself in
relation to the other within a larger
social matrix governed by what principle
utility the useful at this point so he
goes on and he says the certainty of
itself of the the eye is the universal
subject and it's conscious notion is the
essence of all actuality I come to
realize myself not just as this poor
schmuck over here who's got a job and
you know is gonna die in some decades
and but as part of a larger whole and as
a consciousness that can actually take
that in maybe not completely but you
know what I'm not working there's
something like that so he says if then
the useful was merely the alternation of
the moments an alternation which did not
return into its own unity and hence was
still an object for knowing it ceases to
be this so Hegel's fight utility before
was this utility now means something
more so don't mix them up
don't of course totally dissociate them
from each other because there's an out
haben going on here
a sublation a transcendence and
incorporation happening we're early on
of course in the this this section
there's gonna be more tragic and tippet
you know we usually begin the sections
and kind of either puzzles or optimism
and this is an optimistic one so he says
knowing is itself the moment of these
abstract moments it is the universal
self the self of itself as well as the
object and as universal is the self
returning unity of this movement all of
that sounds very good doesn't it sounds
like I as the conscious subject have the
prospect of being able to grasp the
totality isn't that what the whole head
galleon project has been about this
entire time and better yet it's not just
me it's also you you're also the eye in
this case so are all the other eyes out
there so now we have to see where we'll
go from this point
you